the hat that dare not show its brim
that's the focus of tonight's angle
there's so much news to cover every day
in Trump world that you'd think the
press would stick to real reporting and
analysis on important political
developments but new so move over Anna
Wintour because left-wing mal factors
are now in the business of dissing
fashion accessories oh no no not that
one nono not-not-not
ugly of flip-flops no no ya it's that
one bingo hat carries a certain
connotation that provokes a conditioned
reaction for many people especially for
marginalized people America is already
the most punitive developed nation on
earth for poor people for people of
color we throw millions of lives on to
that bonfire every year they just don't
normally look like the teenagers and
Mogga hats this make America great again
hat is just as maddening and frustrating
and triggering for me to look at as a
KKK hood hmm well they've triggered me
in the wake of the Covington Catholic
High School fracas the red maggot hat
has now become a talisman of evil and a
symbol of white supremacy Savannah
Guthrie brought it up with a student at
the center of the controversy Nick
Sandman today on The Today Show do you
think if you weren't wearing that hat
this might not have happened or it might
have been different that's possible but
I would have to assume what mr. fellows
was thinking and I'd rather let him
speak for why he came up to us so the
Red Hat now is apparently the annabelle
of head coverings a thing capable of
unleashing evil wherever seen there is
also a subtext here that's meant to
intimidate we're gonna get into that the
left wants to take away your right to
wear whatever the heck you want now
this is kind of a it's weird it's a
left-wing version of Puritanism their
own version of it where they get to
dictate what goodie fill-in-the-blank is
allowed to wear
anyone who dares to violate their
dictates is either shamed or just
labeled hateful xenophobic misogynistic
unreasonable stupid and of course racist
Bishop Talbert Swan a Harvard Divinity
School grad tweeted when Trayvon Martin
was murdered he all said black parents
shouldn't let their boys wear hoodies if
they didn't want them perceived as thugs
but y'all don't want your boys perceived
as racist little jackasses for wearing
megawhatts hashtag Covington voice mr.
swan will join us in a moment
this left this narrative that a make
America great again hat is akin to
wearing some Nazi uniform it's patently
ridiculous and it's offensive it's just
plain stupid but this is the defamation
and intimidation that the left
happily perpetuates by the way with
little to no pushback predictably of
course never Trump Republicans are also
taking up the chorus Ross Douthat of the
New York Times tweeted in part good
rules for life don't let your Catholic
school students wear Magga hats on it
for a field trip for the March for Life
and of course Bill Kristol never misses
an opportunity to hit the president and
his supporters even when he has his
facts wrong said the contrast between
the calm dignity and quiet strength of
mr. Phillips and the behavior of Magha
brats who have absorbed the spirit of
trumpism this spectacle is a lesson
which all Americans can learn whether a
piece of clothing says feel the Bern or
I'm with her it's all the form of
political expression and thus it is
speech protected by the First Amendment
you can be offended by it but you can't
purposely use it to intimidate and
frighten people and even terrorize them
but today's Left joined by the rabid
never Trump errs are so desperate to be
proven right about the president they
seize on symbols instead of solving
problems guys it's a lot easier isn't it
to brand kids races for what they're
wearing
then to debate adults on things like
immigration and trade policy but for
some the mega hat well it symbolizes
something very different it was
something about
I put this hat on and made me feel like
Superman
you made a Superman now that's my
favorite superhero and you made a
Superman cape
well economy kind of saw this all coming
when he said he didn't want people to
control him to tell him what or how to
think because of the color of his skin
today's real rebels are the kids who
dared to show up for the March for Life
last Friday today's real rebels are the
faithful who refused to genuflect to
what's popular and instead defend what
they think is right today's real rebels
they reject the collectivist mindset of
Hollywood the media and the universities
that obliterate history instead of
actually teaching it and yes today's
rebels will wear Magga hats knowing that
they might be abused for doing so like
the Covington kids were even in the end
it's really not about the Hat is it it's
about 2020 trumpeting fanatics aim to
deprive the president of any opportunity
to brand his re-election campaign in
other words any Trump paraphernalia will
be verboten I thought about this today
and it's actually in its own way a form
of voter intimidation and potentially
lethal with consequences that are
incredibly destructive by the way you
can't scream fire right in a crowded
theater and you can't scream racist when
someone in a crowd wears a hat you don't
like and that's the angle